AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, THE
BIBLE RULES!
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE BEST PART
OF NETFLIX IS PROBABLY SCROLLING
MINDLESSLY THROUGH HYPNOTIC
MENUS FOR AT LEAST 40 MINUTES
BEFORE YOU ACTUALLY PICK
ANYTHING TO WATCH.
AND MAYBE YOU DON'T EVEN WATCH
ANYTHING.
LIKE, YOUR MOVIE-WATCHING FOR
THE NIGHT WAS JUST (BLEEP)ING
LOOKING FOR SOMETHING, AND THEN
YOU'RE LIKE, "WELL, NOW I'M
TIRED.
I TOOK AN EMOTIONAL JOURNEY
THROUGH LOOKING AT-AT BOX ART."
UH, BUT THIS DIGITAL ODYSSEY
THROUGH DIRECT-TO-DVD JASON
STATHAM MOVIES AND CONSPIRACY
DOCUMENTARIES CAN SOMETIMES MESS
WITH YOUR HEAD.
FOR INSTANCE, I RAN ACROSS THIS
HISTORY CHANNEL SERIES CALLED
THE BIBLE RULES, WHICH MY BRAIN
AUTOMATICALLY CHANGED TO THE
BIBLE RULES!
SO, COMEDIANS...
THIS EDGY, BRO-IER-THAN-THOU
VERSION COULD BE THE MAKEOVER
THAT DUSTY OLD TOME NEEDS.
WHAT ARE SOME PASSAGES WE MIGHT
SEE IN THIS MORE EXTREME GOSPEL?
LET'S PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, PAUL.
>> THOU SHALL NOT SEND DICK PICS
UNLESS I'M TOTALLY SURE SHE'S
INTO ME.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ROB HUEBEL.
>> FOR GOD SO LOVED THE WORLD
THAT HE GAVE US THAT STANK WEED,
BRO.
JOHN 4:20.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, YES, AUBREY.
>> UH, THOU SHALT BACK DAT ASS
UP, GIRL.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, AUBREY.
>> UH, THOU SHALT NOT GIVE A
(BLEEP)...
>> HARDWICK: POINTS
(BELL DINGS)
UH, ROB.
>> THOU SHALT NOT HAVE ANY OTHER
GODS BUT NICKELBACK, BRO!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
AUBREY.
>> UM, THY SHALL KEEP HOLY THY
SHARK WEEK.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
THAT'S ACTUALLY A GOOD ONE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY A REALLY GOOD
ONE.
(BELL DINGS)
PAUL.
>> THOU SHALL NOT TALK ABOUT
GAME OF THRONES IF THOU HAVE
READ THE BOOK AND ME THOU HAVE
ONLY WATCHED THINE TV SHOW.
>> HARDWICK: OH, THAT WAS WELL
DONE-- POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ROB.
>> THOU SHALT LOVE THOSE TIG OL'
BITTIES, RIGHT, BRO?
>> HARDWICK: RIGHT.
POINTS.